did you know that a single snake bite
can kill an elephant in just a few hours
and if you're not careful
snake venom can kill you in only 15
minutes but that's from a venomous bite
what if the venom was already collected
and you took a swim in a pool full of
the stuff what would swimming in venom
be like how would snake venom affect
your body and could this actually be
good for you this is what if and here's
what would happen if you fell into a
pool of snake venom so how many snakes
would it take to fill a swimming pool
with venom an average swimming pool has
at least 100,000 liters of water in it
on average a venomous snake can produce
anywhere from one to eight hundred and
fifty milliliters of venom so in order
to fill up an entire pool with snake
venom it would take hundreds of
thousands of snakes to get the venom
you'd have to milk the snakes yep you
can actually milk a snake for its venom
okay now that we have our pool filled
with venom what would happen once you
jumped in you'd probably notice that
swimming and snake venom isn't very
different from swimming in water when
venom is in the snakes fangs
it's about as thick as ketchup but once
it's extracted the viscosity lowers this
makes it easier for the venom to flow
into the preys bloodstream so an entire
pool full of the stuff won't feel all
that different from swimming and water
and what about the smell well it won't
really smell like anything and if you
happen to accidentally taste the venom
it would taste like a somewhat sweet
almost tangy version of water but wait
when do you die I mean this is what if
after all here's a surprise if you were
to swim in snake venom there's a good
chance you wouldn't die the reason is is
that you're swimming in something that's
venomous
rather than your poisonous you see
poison is something that can harm you if
eaten and hailed or touched but venom
needs to be injected into you through a
wound
so swimming in venom wouldn't really do
anything to you that is unless you have
any open wounds if you did go in this
pool with any sort of cut then you'd be
in some big trouble
the venom would quickly seep into your
veins and would give you a number of
issues mainly blood clotting
what was once liquid is now a thick
jelly like paste blood clots would form
eventually clogging your blood vessels
which would then lead to you dying from
a stroke or heart attack but if you're
lucky enough only to get a few drops of
venom in your bloodstream you might be
okay that is if you managed to find
medical assistance relatively quickly in
the u.s. roughly 7,000 people are bitten
by a snake every year of those people
only five end up dying on average you'd
have about 30 to 60 minutes to get some
help once you find it the doctor will
give you an anti-venom treatment and
perhaps a tetanus shot then you can jump
right back in the pool just make sure
you don't have any cuts on your body
this time but maybe we shouldn't be
swimming in this stuff anyway even if it
does no harm perhaps it could be used
for something else
scientists are doing research to find
out if snake venom can be used as
medicine such as for Alzheimer's disease
or to reduce tumors so instead of
playing in snake venom or being afraid
of it
we could use it for good after all
snakes are rarely trying to hurt us and
most snake bites come from people
bothering the reptiles but what would
happen if snakes suddenly grew to be
massive and all of them wanted to hurt
us
well that sounds like a story for
another what if
[Music]